is it possible that this conversation is
happening inside the metaverse created
by you by mera many years from now and
we're doing a memory replay experience i
don't know the answer to that then
you're then i'd be some
some computer construct and
not the person who created that meta
company
but that would truly be meta
right so this could be somebody else
using them the mark zuckerberg avatar
who can do the mark and the lex
conversation replay from
four decades ago when when metaphor it
was first sort of i mean it's not going
to be four decades before we have photo
realistic avatars like this
so i think we're much closer to that
well that's something you talk about is
how passionate you are about the idea of
the avatar representing who you are in
the metaverse so i i do these podcasts
in person
you know i'm a stickler for that because
there's a magic to the in-person
conversation
how long do you think it'll be before
you can have the same kind of magic in
the metaverse the same kind of intimacy
and the chemistry whatever the heck is
there when we're talking a person
how how difficult is it how long before
we have it in the metaverse
well i think that's this is like the key
question right because the
the thing that's different about
virtual and hopefully augmented reality
compared to all other forms of of
digital platforms before is this feeling
of presence right the feeling that
you're right they're in an experience
and that you're there with other people
or in another place
and that's just different from all the
other screens that we have today right
phones tvs all the stuff it's you know
they're trying to in some cases deliver
experiences that feel
um
high fidelity but at no point do you
actually feel like you're in it right at
some level your content is trying to
sort of convince you that this is a
realistic thing that's happening but all
of the kind of subtle signals are
telling you now you're looking at a
screen
so
the question about how you develop these
systems is like
what are all of the things that make the
physical world all the different cues so
i i think on
visual presence
and
spatial audio
we're making reasonable progress spatial
audio makes a huge deal i don't know if
you've tried this experience um
workrooms that we launched where you
have meetings and you know i i basically
made a rule for you know all of the the
top you know management folks at the
company that they need to be doing
standing meetings in in work rooms
already right i feel like we got a dog
food this you know it's this is how
people are going to work um in the
future so we we have to adopt this now
and there are already a lot of things
that i think feel significantly better
than
than like typical zoom meetings even
though the avatars are a lot lower
fidelity
um you know the idea that you have
spatial audio you're around a table in
vr with people
if someone's talking from over there it
sounds like it's talking from over there
you can see you know the the the arm
gestures and stuff feel more natural um
you can have side conversations which is
something that you can't really do in
zoom i mean i guess you can text someone
over like
out of band but
and if you're actually sitting around a
table with people
you know you can lean over and whisper
to the person next to you and like have
a conversation that you can't you know
that that you can't really do with um
in in um
in just video communication so i think
it's interesting
in what ways
some of these things already feel more
real than a lot of the technology that
we have
even when the visual fidelity isn't
quite there but i think it'll get there
over the next few years now i mean you
were asking about comparing that to the
true physical world not zoom or
something like that and there i mean i
think you have feelings of like
temperature
um you know olfactory
obviously touch right we're working on
haptic gloves um you know the the sense
that you want to be able to you know put
your hands down and feel some pressure
from the table
um you know all these things i think are
going to be really critical to be able
to keep up this illusion that you're in
a world and that you're fully present in
this world but i don't know i think
we're going to have a lot of these
building blocks within you know the next
10 years or so and even before that i
think it's amazing how much you're just
going to be able to build with software
that sort of masks some of these things
um
i i realize i'm going long but i you
know i was told we have a few hours here
yeah so it's here for five to six hours
yeah so i mean it's look i mean that
that's that's on the shorter end of the
congressional testimonies i've done um
but it's um
but
you know one of the things that we found
with
with hand presence right so the the
earliest vr you just have the headset
and then um that was cool you could look
around you feel like you're in a place
but you don't feel like you're really
able to interact with it until you have
hands and then there was this big
question where once you got hands what's
the right way to represent them and
initially
all of our assumptions was okay when i
look down and see my hands in the
physical world i see an arm and it's
gonna be super weird if you see you know
just your hand
um
but it turned out to not be the case
because there's this issue with your
arms which is like what's your elbow
angle and if the elbow angle that we're
kind of interpolating based on where um
your hand is and where your headset is
actually isn't accurate it creates this
very uncomfortable feeling where it's
like oh like my arm is actually out like
this but it's like showing it in here
and that actually broke the the feeling
of presence a lot more whereas it turns
out that if you just show the hands and
you don't show the arms um
it actually is fine for people so i
think that there's
a bunch of these interesting
psychological cues where it'll be more
about getting the right details right
and i think a lot of that will be
possible even over you know a few year
period or five year period and we won't
need like every single thing to be
solved to deliver this like full sense
of presence yeah it's a fascinating
psychology question of what is
the essence
that makes in-person conversation
special it's like emojis are able to
convey emotion really well even though
they're obviously not photorealistic
and so in that same way just like you're
saying just showing the hands is able to
create a comfortable expression with
your hands so i wonder what that is you
know people in in the world wars used to
write letters and you can fall in love
with just writing letters you don't need
to see each other in person you can
convey emotion you can a
depth of uh experience with just words
so that's a i think a fascinating place
to explore psychology of like how do you
find that intimacy yeah and you know the
way that i come to all of this stuff is
you know i basically studied psychology
and computer science so all of the work
that i do
is sort of at the intersection of those
things i think most of the other big
tech companies are building
technology for you to interact with what
i care about is building technology to
help people interact with each other so
it's i think it's a somewhat different
approach than most of the other tech
entrepreneurs and and big companies come
at this from
um
and
a lot of the lessons
in terms of how i think about designing
products come from
some just basic elements of psychology
right in terms of you know
our brains you know you can compare to
the brains of other animals you know
we're very wired to specific things
facial expressions right we're
we're very visual right so compared to
other animals i mean that's that's
clearly the the the main sense that most
people have um but there's a whole part
of your brain that's just kind of
focused on on reading facial cues so you
know when we're designing the next
version of quest or the vr headset a big
focus for us is face tracking and
basically eye tracking so you can make
eye contact which again isn't really
something that you can do over a video
conference it's sort of amazing how much
um how far video conferencing has gotten
without the ability to make eye contact
right it's sort of a bizarre thing if
you think about it you're like looking
at someone's face um you know sometimes
for you know an hour when you're in a
meeting and like
you looking at their eyes
to them doesn't look like you're looking
at their eyes so it's a
you're always looking i mean past each
other i guess
yeah i guess you're right you're not
sitting where you're trying to right
you're trying like a lot of times i mean
or at least i find myself i'm trying to
look into the other person's eyes they
don't feel like you're looking yeah so
then the question is am i supposed to
look at the camera so that way you can
you know have a sensation that i'm
looking at you i think that that's an
interesting question and then you know
with vr
um today even without
eye tracking and knowing what your eyes
are actually looking at you can fake it
reasonably well right so you can look at
like where the head pose is and if it
looks like i'm kind of looking in your
general direction then you can sort of
assume that maybe there's some eye
contact intended and and you can do it
in a way where it's okay maybe not it's
like a maybe it's not a fixated stare
but um
but it's it's somewhat natural but once
you have actual eye tracking you can you
can do it for real and i think that's
really important stuff so when i think
about meta's contribution to this field
i have to say it's not clear to me that
any of the other companies that are
focused on
on the metaverse or on virtual and
augmented reality are going to
prioritize putting these features in the
hardware because like everything they're
trade-offs right i mean they it adds it
adds some weight to the device maybe it
adds some thickness you could totally
see another company taking the approach
of let's just make the lightest and
thinnest thing possible but you know i
want us to design the most human thing
possible
that that creates the richest sense of
presence and um because so much of of
human
um emotion and expression comes from
these like micro movements if i like
move my eyebrow you know millimeter you
will notice and that like means
something um so the fact that we're
losing these signals and a lot of
communication i think is is is a loss
and it's so it's not like okay there's
one feature and you add this then it all
of a sudden is going to feel like we
have real presence you can sort of look
at how the the human brain works and how
we we express and and kind of read
emotions and you can just build a
roadmap of that you know of just what
are the most important things to try to
unlock over a five to ten year period
and just try to make the experience more
and more human and social
you